what you said
oh
if you had the choice to get rid of your
dress would you
no i would yes i would yes yes i would
just
no i wouldn't because it makes me unique
and it makes me who i am
zach i love you i love you
can you drive with tourette
yes you can i have my permit and i can
get my license
but i don't because
my tics and anxiety are too out of
control we need to get them under
control
do you take in your sleep i don't think
i do i've been told i do but i've also
been told that i don't
are you embarrassed by your tics yes i
am i'm extremely embarrassed
but and it is really hard to post on
social media about it
as i never really used to tell anybody
and now
a lot of people know what have your tics
calm down since we're out of school
no no no yes yes no they haven't they
i've
they have actually gotten a lot worse
because of the anxiety about everything
that's going on
why do you always say koi because a
youtuber that i watched who has
tourette's has that as a tick
and i picked it up probably like two
years ago
so that's why have you ever called 911
because of a tick
yes i have wire don't lie to yourself
chicken um i have not but there is this
setting on my phone where if you click
the on and off button like six times
fast
it calls 911 and that has happened when
you're having a tick attack do you
remember what you say
or do sometimes i do and sometimes i
don't
also that's how it is with anxiety
attacks i usually don't remember the
anxiety attacks but tick attacks
i you know it's a patent do i have a
favorite tick yes all the ones about
zach
[Music]
you